como estamos en mitad de una pandemia
todos los restaurantes que están
alrededor de esta zona están cerrados y
los comercios están como podéis ver aquí
tapiados también no solamente por el cob
y también por el miedo a que vuelvan
esas protestas esto es lo más lejos que
hemos podido llegar como periodistas
como veis aquí están todos los
compañeros contando este momento
histórico de esa toma de posesión de
baire en que arrancaba a las 11 11 y
media de la mañana
de momento a la mañana está
transcurriendo muy tranquilas y que ha
habido un pequeño enfrentamiento entre
algunos manifestantes que han venido
aquí del movimiento blacklight matear ha
llegado la policía querían entrar a
atravesar estos controles que veis aquí
detrás de mí por los que nosotros hemos
tenido que pasar y hemos tenido que
acreditar nos ahora sí que es verdad que
esa seguridad empieza a levantar un
poquito más la mano empiezan a dejar
entrar a más gente pero desde luego no
quieren que esos manifestantes se
acerquen al capitolio y que pueda haber
ningún tipo de problema mamen en estos
últimos cuatro años en eeuu el trato a
la prensa fue muy diferente el que le
dio el presidente el expresidente trump
a los diferentes medios de comunicación
la prensa cómo ha sido recibida el día
de hoy justo en este día de transición
pero desde luego santiago el trabajo ha
sido muchísimo más fácil tenemos que
decir que en todo momento desde el
equipo de comunicación de bailén hemos
estado recibiendo emails y
actualizaciones de cómo iba a
transcurrir este evento de todos los
pasos que estaba dando el ya nombrado el
ya del conmemorado presidente y ha sido
desde luego mucho más fácil nada que ver
como decías con la anterior presidencia
hay una imagen que me ha llamado
muchísimo la atención y es que hace unos
pocos minutos había aquí un periodista
que iba equipado como si fuese uno de
estos militares que están viendo detrás
de mí para proteger la ciudad y eso te
hace hacerte una idea de lo que ha sido
trabajar como periodista en estos cuatro
años que ha habido mucha tensión en las
calles no solamente a la hora de conocer
la información sino también a la hora de
trabajar en las calles y como decía pues
yo creo que a partir de ahora llega a
una era completamente distinta en la que
la prensa de alguna manera y eso es pero
vamos a tener lo más fácil
pues por lo menos este primer día en
este día de ceremonia de posesión las
cosas empiezan a marchar a un ritmo
distinto mamen gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad de washington allí muy
cerca del capitolio aparente normalidad
hasta ahora todo ha estado en calma no
hay reportes de ningún tipo de
altercados de gran calibre ya lo decía
mamen no ha habido ningún tipo de
enfrentamiento